legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting in Mobile why is it that
it seems like the police can get away
with murder isn't there a limit doesn't
the Constitution protect you and why
can't you sue the police for violating
your rights the Fourth Amendment to the
US Constitution provides that the right
of the people to be secure in their
persons houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures shall not be violated most
citizens believe that the Constitution
therefore protects them against illegal
searches unlawful arrests and excessive
use of force
and this is definitely true on paper but
in practice sometimes things go sideways
for example on August 15 2014 she DS
West and her children returned home to
find her house surrounded by police
officers informed her that they were
looking for her ex-boyfriend who was a
fugitive West told police that she had
told him to gather his things and leave
the house but after police threatened to
arrest West if he was still inside she
consented to have her house searched she
handed an officer her keys to the house
and told them that her dog was still in
sight but rather than using the keys to
the house a SWAT team was activated the
SWAT team spent three hours making a
plan to besiege the house then they
deployed to her home and through tear
gas grenades into the house blasted the
back door off the hinges and sprayed
tear gas on every surface of the home
the ex-boyfriend was not in the house
but when West finally returned to the
home she found the house destroyed there
were holes in walls and ceilings their
belongings were saturated with a residue
of sticky tear gas and the home was
littered with debris from broken window
glass West sued police for violating her
Fourth Amendment rights the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals threw the case
out finding that the police were
entitled to qualified immunity not just
on the reasonableness of the search but
also on the question of whether they had
exceeded the scope of West's consent in
a way shinee's West was lucky she lost
property and her home was damaged but
she walked away with her life others
recently have not been so lucky the
question is what good are rights on
paper when there's no one around to
enforce those rights today we're gonna
look at the claims that individuals
might have against the government when
they violate one's constitutional rights
and the complicated legal defense that
sometimes seems to let them off the hook
the defense called qualified immunity so
can courts ever question the decisions
of the police or does the law need a
course correction
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because a lot of people are
wondering what happens when the police
violates someone's rights and if it ever
happened to you what could you do to sue
government officials for violating the
Constitution well the most important law
that allows people to sue for violations
of their constitutional rights it's
found in 42 USC 1983 which by shorthand
is usually just referred to as a section
1983 claim which was originally part of
the Civil Rights Act of 1871 aka the Klu
Klux Klan Act the Act passed in the
aftermath of the Civil War when Congress
sought to enforce the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments after black Americans gained
the right to vote the number of blacks
killed by whites actually doubled and in
some cases law enforcement joined the
racist mobs Congress believed that
citizens needed a way to sue government
officials in federal courts since state
courts in the south were largely
unwilling to prosecute these violations
you actually see this in a fair number
of federal laws that sometimes the
federal government has to pass various
laws as a reaction to the states being
unwilling or unable to enforce or
prosecute the state law itself however
even after section 1983 was passed four
decades federal courts created elaborate
excuses that sent most 1983 claims back
down to the state courts where the
claims died it took another 80 years
before the Supreme Court changed this
reading section 1983 expansively so that
citizens whose rights were violated had
a civil cause of action against the
officers who violated their federal
rights and that's generally what section
1983 does it gives a private right of
action to citizens whose rights have
been violated by the federal or state
governments that's not a claim that
really existed at common law so it
required a federal law to create that
private right of action and in 1961 the
Supreme Court decided Monroe versus Pape
which established the legal standard for
proving modern excessive force claims
this case involved a warrantless entry
into a home by 13 Chicago police
officers in the middle of the night the
police were looking for a murder suspect
upon entry they held the parents and
children at gunpoint naked police
detained the father for ten hours and
refused him an attorney eventually the
police let the father go with no charges
the Supreme Court applied the text of
section 1983 as permitting lawsuit
against government officials the text
says that quote every person who under
color of any statute ordinance
regulation custom or usage deprive
someone of the rights privileges or
immunities secured by the Constitution
shall be liable to the injured party
through a lawsuit the meaning of the
phrase color of state law means that
it's a power that's quote possessed by
virtue of state law and made possible
only because the wrongdoer is clothed in
the authority of state law and while the
city of Chicago could not be sued since
it was not a person under those statute
the the police officers couldn't be sued
even if they acted outside of their
scope of authority because they were
acting under the color of law this
decision allowed individual government
employees to be sued for the acts that
violate the Constitution or statues and
in a later case the Supreme Court held
that a municipality could also be liable
for the actions of its employees for a
municipality be held liable the the
plaintiff must prove that the officers
acted pursuant to an official policy or
government custom that violated
someone's constitutional rights even if
the custom or policy was not formally
approved so you can imagine there's a
big difference between being able to sue
an individual government official for
their acts and being able to sue a
municipality only when there is a policy
or procedure that led to that violation
of Rights
now coextensive with the Supreme Court's
jurisprudence in creating these
constitutional rights and defining
violations the Supreme Court also
developed a legal doctrine called
qualified immunity that often tends to
let government officials off the hook
with the recent protests across the
country and additional evidence of
police misconduct a lot of people have
been talking about qualified immunity
and some legislators have even talked
about rolling back the qualified
immunity doctrine there is nothing about
what the president announced today that
would hold police officers who break the
rules and break the law accountable so
what is qualified immunity well
qualified immunity is a judicially
created doctrine that gives government
officials a shield from personal
liability for violating a person's
federal constitutional rights the
qualified immunity doctrine holds that a
government official is immune from
personal liability if the official did
not violate a quote clearly established
law qualified immunity applies to state
local and federal officials it is not
available for claims against
municipalities or claims for
economic relief like an injunction
requiring the government to act or
refrain from acting and when government
officials are sued qualified immunity
functions as an affirmative defense that
they can raise which can bar damages
even if they committed unlawful acts so
long as the actor can prove that the
violated right was not clearly
established at the time that the
violation occurred now it might seem
weird to have the federal government
grant a private right of action only to
have the Supreme Court rollback that
protection by offering immunity to the
very people who are accused of violating
constitutional rights so let's talk
about where this defense of qualified
immunity comes from and why we allow it
not surprisingly the origin of qualified
immunity is complex and controversial
the Supreme Court traced the concept to
the immunities available at common law
torts hundreds of years ago the court
reasoned that when Congress passed
section 1983 back in 1871 it must have
also intended to incorporate immunities
into the Act some legal experts believe
this doctrine is built on very shaky
legal ground but the court also had
practical reasons for offering officials
qualified immunity the idea is that
officers should not be found liable for
doing things they didn't know were
unconstitutional at the time that they
committed those acts and the US Supreme
Court hoped that the standard would
enable lower courts to dismiss in
substantial nuisance claims which would
lead to less disruption of government
and fewer cost to society now advocates
of qualified immunity say that it lets
government officials work without
subjecting them to distraction extra
scrutiny and the burdens of a lawsuit
like discovery and testimony now in
thinking about the test for qualified
immunity to determine whether it applies
there's a big Supreme Court case called
Harlow that really changed the game now
the Supreme Court's old qualified
immunity test invited courts to review
the facts in great detail and examine an
officer's motivations when it came to
the issue of whether officers acted in
good faith both subjective and objective
factors were considered in other words
what the officer was thinking as well as
the objective facts surrounding that
decision a defendant seeking immunity
needed to show that they acted both with
permissible intentions and without
ignorant or disregard of the settled
indisputable law and when courts looked
at the subjective prong the focus was on
the officials motives and intentions the
focus of the objective inquiry
on whether the applicable law was
settled or ambiguous essentially a legal
question a court had to apply both tests
to the challenged act before immunity
attached to the defendant the modern
concept of qualified immunity was
announced by the Supreme Court in a case
called Harlow versus Fitzgerald in 1982
the court decreed the qualified immunity
gives an official immunity from
liability unless one the official
violated the plaintiffs constitutional
rights and to the right the official
violated was clearly established at the
time the current test just doesn't allow
for subjective questioning of an
officer's motives and intentions the
courts have repeatedly said that the
standard does not allow them to
second-guess officers and that hindsight
is 20/20 so let's look at some of the
problems that this standard invites the
first is that the clearly established
right requirement requires almost
identical precedent to be of any value
at all so for a lawsuit against police
to move forward the plaintiff has to
show that the official violated the
plaintiffs constitutional rights and
that that constitutional right was
clearly established but in practice what
that has meant is that a court will find
that a constitutional right was clearly
established if there was a prior case
that found that that constitutional
right was violated and you can see that
this turns into a bit of a catch-22 and
the real rub here is that since 2009 the
Supreme Court has allowed courts to
address these two conditions in either
order so generally this means that
government officials can only be held
liable if an appeals court or the US
Supreme Court has already held that
government officer violated the
Constitution by engaging in basically
the exact same conduct under precisely
the same circumstances and on top of
that there is a doctrine of judicial
restraint that says that courts should
only answer the legal questions that are
in front of them and avoid questions
that they don't absolutely have to
answer and in practice what that means
for section 1983 cases that lower courts
have gone out of their way to avoid
answering whether there was in fact a
clearly established constitutional right
instead they searched other court
decisions to look for an identical case
and if an identical case isn't found
then they dismiss the lawsuit saying
that there isn't a clearly established
constitutional right for example in the
case of Cockrell versus the city of
Cincinnati the court refused to decide
whether a person fleeing from the scene
of a non
misdemeanor in this case it was
jaywalking who was offering no other
resistance and not disobeying official
commands had a clearly established right
not to be tased the court skipped that
question and went to the second question
whether the right was clearly
established the appeals court held that
it was not clearly established that
using a Taser on a jaywalker violated
that person's civil rights because no
other court had faced basically
identical circumstances and as a result
the officer received qualified immunity
this has created a world where courts
have not fully developed what
constitutional rights exist when it
comes to confrontations with the police
this is the same problem that Chinese
West ran into in the Ninth Circuit the
court agreed that it was preposterous to
assume that the West consented to the
destruction of her home when she handed
the officer her keys which is the same
thing that happened in a video I covered
recently where the police literally blew
up a house you can get a link to that
video in the description but the
majority of the Ninth Circuit even wrote
that no reasonable person would have
understood West's consent to encompass
shooting tear gas canisters into her
house yet the officers were entitled to
qualified immunity since no other court
had articulated a clear constitutional
right that was violated in a similar
situation but you could see the opposite
argument being made as well the fact
that no other officers have engaged in
an insane asylum they were given consent
to search might bolster West's claim
that her rights were violated and thus
it was more clearly established because
it was such a preposterous thing to do
obviously not many officers would think
to do such a thing under the
circumstances probably because they
thought it would violate someone's
Fourth Amendment rights but under the
Supreme Court's jurisprudence the
absence of effectively identical cases
means that officers shouldn't be liable
because they couldn't have known that it
was wrong based on some court case but
sometimes even Supreme Court justices
can't always agree on whether a right is
clearly established or not in Safford
Unified School District number one
versus reading eight justices concluded
that the school officials strip-searched
of a 13 year old student for ibuprofen
violated the Fourth Amendment however
six justices held that the Fourth
Amendment law was not clearly
established at the time of the search
two justices Stevens and Ginsburg found
that the Fourth Amendment law was
clearly established meanwhile Justice
Thomas found that there was
Fourth Amendment violation at all
regardless of whether was clearly
established or not
so basically school officials got to
strip-search a 13 year old without
liability another example of qualified
immunity gone arguably wrong is the
example of prince mccoy prince mccoy was
an inmate in texas while he was a
prisoner at prison guard
frustrated by a different inmate in a
completely different cell shot McCoy in
the face with pepper sprayed McCoy
after this incident sued the prison
guard
however the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals ruled against McCoy and held
that the guard was in fact entitled to
qualified immunity all because while the
court had previously said that guards
can't punch or tase defenseless inmates
the court had never previously said that
jailers can't use pepper spray on
defenseless inmates locked in their
cells and the examples continue there
are other cases where the courts have
said that police were entitled to
qualified immunity after they outright
stole cash from victims destroyed homes
in the lect case which I have covered on
this particular channel and they've
gotten away with shooting children all
without consequence because of the
qualified immunity doctrine another
issue with qualified immunity and
section 1983 is that reasonable mistakes
can be made
the Supreme Court has said that the
Fourth Amendment requires quote not that
officers always be correct but that they
always be reasonable the qualified
immunity standard requires the court to
look objectively at whether the
government official believed in light of
the circumstances that they were not
violating a person's rights now before
Harlow a plaintiff could survive a
qualified immunity defense by alleging
malice and finding enough facts that the
officers history suggested such malice
but not so any more and officers are
allowed to make mistakes officers are
often given immunity for both mistakes
of fact and of law for an example of how
an officer can survive a mistake of fact
consider the death of Marquess heads
both during a traffic stop police have
been called to a gas station after
someone reported that Hudspeth was
speeding talking on a cell phone and
intoxicated although Hudspeth wasn't in
fact unarmed Shreveport police testified
that they thought his cell phone was a
gun now I will warn you the dashcam
video of the event is hard to watch
fast-forward 30 seconds if you
want to avoid it in the video you can
see Hudspeth walking away from officers
they shoot him several times in the back
the court in looking at this situation
found that the actions of the police
officers were justifiable and said that
the fact that he was unarmed and his
back was turned was more or less
irrelevant the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals characterized the video as
providing undisputable evidence that
Hudspeth attempted to flee and according
to the court officers had an articulable
basis to believe it heads both was armed
and could reasonably have perceived him
as posing a threat of serious bodily
harm essentially the court said that it
was reasonable for the police to assume
that Hudspeth had a gun even though his
back was turned and he in fact was
unarmed now that's a government official
a police officer making a mistake of
fact but officers can also have a
reasonable but mistaken belief as to
what the law actually requires and still
receive qualified immunity in Anderson
vs. Crichton federal officers conducted
a warrantless forcible nighttime entry
into the home of the Crichton family
looking for a bank robber the bank
robber was not there and there was no
emergency justification for the
warrantless search however the Supreme
Court ruled that even though the search
was not legally justified officers in
the case shouldn't be held liable for
making a reasonable mistake about the
law itself this is probably something to
keep in mind as you watch the Louisville
Police defend their actions in the
Brianna Taylor case Taylor was killed
after the police executed a search
warrant on her apartment they were
searching for two people who were
actually already in police custody and
it turned out to be the wrong apartment
police will be sued and their defense
will probably be that the police made a
legal and factual mistake but they were
reasonable under the circumstances and
if the court agrees then qualified
immunity is likely to prevent the suit
from going forward which brings us to
the third issue with qualified immunity
which is that it seems to encourage
deadly force the Supreme Court's most
recent decisions seem to allow the use
of deadly force in almost any kind of
situation for example in 2014 the
Supreme Court decided the case of
Mullenix versus Luna which involved a
state trooper shooting a driver who led
troopers on
a high-speed chase now there's no
dispute that the driver was potentially
intoxicated and that he had threatened
to shoot the officers if they didn't end
their chase the officers decided to use
spike strips in the path of the car
which was designed to puncture the tires
and the pursuit
however trooper Mullenix without his
supervisors permission fired six shots
to disable the car before it hit the
spike strip killing the driver the court
found that Mullenix was entitled to
qualified immunity because there was not
a clearly established right prohibiting
his conduct in its reasonableness
discussion the court closely analyzed
the facts as understood by the officer
and decided that his actions were in
furtherance of Public Safety even if
they went against his supervisors
decision to use the spike strips the
Supreme Court said the qualified
immunity protects actions in the hazy
border between excessive and acceptable
force in dissent justice Sotomayor
argued that it was clearly established
that an officer in the troopers position
should not have fired those shots
she also questioned the majority's
finding of a governmental interest
because there was no evidence of quote
any possible marginal gain in shooting
at the car over using the spike strips
already in place moreover she argued
that the governmental interest is not
quote whether the car should be stopped
but rather quote how the car should be
stopped this is the major debate that
the courts qualified immunity
jurisprudence has inspired can courts
ever tell police that they should have
picked another option the way this
standard is interpreted increasingly
means that the court simply won't
substitute its judgment for the officers
and there are certainly many reasons why
courts engage in this kind of analysis
that I won't go into at the moment and
it's easy to imagine that this leads to
a lack of accountability and someone say
that's a good thing that we shouldn't
have judges and juries second-guessing
police actions when they're far removed
from the heat of the action itself but
it's easy to see why this removes a
check on the power and leads to less
accountability and it's an open question
whether more accountability in the form
of judgments against officers would
cause them to make better decisions at
all and this was one of the issues that
came to a head in the US Supreme Court
summary reversal of a deadly force case
in Casella versus Hughes which lowered
the legal standard of acceptable conduct
even further without oral argument or
even ordering briefing on the case in
Casella three officers responded to a
call that a woman was engaging in
erratic behavior with a knife the 911
was hacking a tree with a kitchen knife
when the officers arrived they found the
woman holding a large kitchen knife at
her side about six feet from another
woman the woman with the knife walked
several steps down her driveway toward
the officers officer Casella fired four
shots through a chain-link fence
seriously injuring her the Supreme Court
found that the officers separated from
Hughes by a chain-link fence still had
reasons to fear that she might have
attacked the other person and because
she did not immediately drop the knife
in response to their commands the court
held that the police couldn't have
foreseen that any court would consider
this excessive use of force justices
Ginsburg and Sotomayor dissented writing
that the ruling quote is not just wrong
in the law it also sends an alarming
signal to law enforcement officers in
the public that officers quote can shoot
first and think later and it tells the
public that palpably unreasonable
conduct will go unpunished
and there are certainly a lot of people
who would agree with the dissenting
opinion here that qualified immunity has
gone too far in that there aren't enough
restrictions on police it's just that
the majority of the justices on the
Supreme Court don't feel the same way
so as we think about what comes next
states certainly have the ability to
divert from the Supreme Court's
jurisprudence regarding qualified
immunity and some states have in fact
done that they have effectively created
state-based causes of action that allow
people who have been wronged by
government officials to sue the state
other states in fact most don't allow
that because they simply don't want to
have to pay out to victims of state
actors but even if states don't create
causes of action and don't remove the
immunity we can potentially expect
action from Congress after George
Floyd's death Democrat Ayanna Presley
and Republican turned libertarian Justin
Amash introduced legislation that would
end qualified immunity for all public
employees including non law enforcement
personnel the Amash presley bill called
the end qualified immunity Act would
overrule Supreme Court precedent reading
qualified immunity into section 1983 and
it would also clarify the earlier
interpretations of section 1983 which
gave police immunity when they acted
generally in good faith during the
performance of their job duties wouldn't
apply this would presumably eliminate
situations where courts gave police
illegal pass when they
tragic mistakes such as serving a
warrant on the wrong address which we
saw in the Brianna Taylor case
additionally Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi introduced the Justice in
policing Act which would also eliminate
qualified immunity as a defense under
section 1983 but only for police
officers this legislation proposes a ban
on chokeholds no-knock warrants in drug
cases and eliminates religious and
racial profiling and makes it easier for
police to be prosecuted it would also
make lynching a federal hate crime and
this legislation would also develop a
federal use of force standard now both
of these bills have a long long way to
go before they ever become law in this
country but this last bill in particular
has already over 200 co-sponsors and it
appears that the house is going to hold
hearings on these proposed reforms but
the point of section 1983 claims is to
right the wrongs of police and of
governmental misconduct and rolling that
qualified immunity would certainly go a
long way towards getting compensation
for victims of such misconduct but it's
no silver bullet and I've talked about a
lot of potential police reforms that
could go into effect and could also make
a difference but ending qualified
immunity while it might be a step
forward won't end police misconduct
overnight and if you're out there
protesting and become the victim of
police misconduct you'll need to call
your lawyer and if you use ting mobile
at least your call with your civil
rights lawyer will be super clear it's
it's funny because it's true and it's
also terrible but what's not terrible is
ting Mobile which is a different kind of
mobile provider with ting you only pay
for the actual data and services you use
at the end of the month and because
you're paying for only what you actually
use ting customers pay on average just
twenty three dollars per month for one
device and ting provides great LTE
coverage because it uses the Verizon
t-mobile and Sprint networks so you get
the benefit of three massive networks
wherever you go which can be important
in case the police shut down one of the
cell services you'll be able to use all
the other networks to make your call to
your lawyer and with ting you can use
almost any cell phone including the
newest iPhones and Google pixel phones
and you can use the same phone number
you're using right now there's no
contract no overage fees and no other
carrier tricks you just pay a fair price
for the talk text and data that you use
every month and ting has award-winning
customer service because they don't have
to put money into brick-and-mortar
stores which are likely to get their
windows smashed in any way so they can
pour their resources into their phone
and online support and if you have any
issues you can just give them a call and
immediately talk to a real person
instead of having to go to one of those
in-person stores and with ting
especially if you're around Wi-Fi all
the time which most of us are
considering we're working from home
you'll end up paying way less than you
do right now of course some people
should pay $200 a month for unlimited
data if they're nowhere near their homes
but if you're surrounded by Wi-Fi all
day you might be paying hundreds of
dollars more completely unnecessarily
and ting gives you the option to pay
only for what you use so if you go to
legal Eagle ENCOM you can use your last
bill to compare just how much you would
save and legal eagles will get a $25
service credit by going to legal eagle
ting comm and that can cover your entire
first month and since there are no
contracts you can try it for a month no
strings attached again all you have to
do is click on the link in the
description or go to legal eagle ENCOM
and get a $25 credit for whatever
service you want plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel so do
you agree with my analysis do you think
that we should abrogate qualified
immunity leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other real law
reviews talking about all the crazy
stuff that's happening with the protest
Cove in nineteen button and basically
all the legal news there's a lot of it
so just click on this playlist and I'll
see you in court hopefully not literally